the two percent difference is as soon as  you get an idea you take action idea to  action a data action i need an action  right away you do it you get an idea  trusted idea comes from somewhere and  you do it just go off and do it but it's  not going to be perfect what we normally  do is we plan right we plan to get 100  we have this idea what's the perfect  plan to get it completed 100 done don't  do that because you use all that energy  when you're feeling bold and confident  into planning that's silly you're going  to lose because you're going to wake up  tomorrow different person the energy  will be gone that momentum the  confidence that boldness will be gone  you use that boldness into action